hello everyone and welcome to an
exciting game from round 7 of this
year's Super bet chess classic it is
Anish giri versus a classical world
champion ding lyren who already lost one
game to alireza Fury if you've seen it
um it's been a it's been a really tough
tournament for him uh so let's see what
happened in this one and uh yeah the the
the game is so complicated to follow to
watch and to analyze that I I can only
imagine how difficult it was to actually
play this so I apologize if there will
be a you know uh maybe a few lines more
than I would usually show but it's uh
such a complicated game I absolutely
must show them and there is one
particular line that basically ends the
game on the spot that I will not show I
will only show it after we check out the
entire game because it's like it's it's
a 20-something moves line that's a force
to win uh so I will show that as well
but only at the end of the video if you
guys will be interested so let's check
it out Anish has the white pieces and he
opens with Ponte E4 as he usually does
with Ponte E5 Knight to F3 Knight the C6
and Bishop to C4 he goes for the Italian
game with Bishop to C5 nope we don't we
have Knight to F6 the two knights
defense and now Pawn to D3 going for the
modern Bishop's opening and Bishop the
C5 the Joko pianissimo uh with Bishop to
G5 and now Ponte H6 attacking the bishop
Bishop the H4 important to D6 so this
has all been played before nothing new
here uh interestingly Anish himself
uh played this position with the black
pieces he had it against even charge
when he uh played in the in the grand
Chester in Zagreb in 2019 and Anish lost
this with the black pieces so uh as he's
a great theoretician he also uh has uh
spent time actually playing this
position only with reversed colors so C3
we have pawned the A5 stopping B4 of
course and now Knight beta D2 with Basha
back to A7 reaching the position that he
had against charity Shin Zagreb in 2019
but charge went A3 here with the white
pieces Dinka sorry anigo spawn to A4 and
it is now as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game that's not really
true there are some two very low level
games I found in the database that were
played on some website uh but other than
that no top rated games reaching this
position so I I feel it's okay that we
call it a completely new game so here uh
ding castles with Ponte H3 and now Pawn
to G5 and what does Anish do well he
goes for a pawn sacrifice for a peace
sacrifice is Knight captures on G5 and
it's a pretty standard move you would
see in a in the Joker pianissimo if you
remember yeah there was a very similar
uh peace sacrifice it's basically a
piece for two Pawn so I don't really
consider this a real sacrifice uh uh in
the game casting kayak in in the World
Chess Championship match that also uh
resulted in a draw uh but here okay King
to G7 you know that the Knight on F6
will come under attack and the Knight
cannot move so white definitely has
compensation for the sacrificed piece
with Queen to F3 Bishop to E6 uh and now
Knights the F1 the Knight also wants to
join the attack if you can get something
like Knight G3 Knight H5 check it's
basically game over but you know that
the Rook will come to h8 so you will not
be able to use the
at H5 Square so here instead after Rook
day trade uh Knight the E3 by Anish and
now Queen to E7 preparing to bring the
other Rook into the game we have Queen
side Castles by Anish playing uh truly
uh in the style of of great attackers
and now comes with Rook 8 to G8 and this
is a bit slow biting Bishop capture 73
was that was the way to go uh because
you do not want to allow this Knight a
particular move but that's something
that we are going to discuss uh a bit
later so Rook 8 to G8 we have Rook H the
F1 now uh signaling that okay if uh
Bishop characters Knight at any point
then F captures maybe the f file opens
up or even if not maybe I move the queen
maybe I play F4 open up DF file this way
The Rook will be very useful on the f
file we have Knight the B8 binding and
here uh this is the position that I
talked about and I've allowed the engine
to Crunch the numbers to really go hard
at it to the some depth of of 50 and the
engine finds a beautiful will win here
for white but we are not going to
discuss that because it's such a such a
disgusting Engine line there is no way
that anyone finds this so let's just
check out the game and only after we
check out the game will we return to
this position so Pawn to D4 uh Anish
opens up the the position as of course
you uh you want you sacrifice the
material you want to go for the black
king so here e captures on the 4C
captures and not Knight beta D7 by Ding
and now Pawn to E5 uh you would probably
expect the C Pawn to D5 here because it
kind of traps the bishop here the
problem is uh look at this Knight to D5
move attacks the night uh the queen
attacks the bishop uh once you play
something like Queen captures and F6
okay you want to trade queens now
because there's no other way to do it
King captures D captures an E6 uh you
would have F captures on E6 and now
after the bishop moves uh there's the
bishop captures on E3 and you would
basically get this position where white
is up a pawn but it's a double D Pawn so
nothing spectacular even if anyone is to
be preferred here it's probably black so
instead Anish goes for Ponte E5 maybe an
odd looking move because uh okay uh the
five Pawn is attacked twice but the idea
is that after black captures uh Anisha
wants to play Pawn to D5 so here Dean
captures Pawn to D5 now trapping the
bishop here there are no squares for
this bishop and now Queen to B4 and this
is where the game gets extremely
complicated
uh because here we have Queen to E2 and
this is a beautiful move by Anish it's
the only move that allows him to push
for the win Now problem is if you
capture an E6 which is kind of what you
want to do then you can just eliminate
the defender of the bishop and C4 Bishop
captures with check and the problem is
everything comes with check Queen
captures and C4 comes with check after
King B1 Queen captures and E6 removes
the attacker of the Knight on D7 and now
you are perfectly fine of course you are
much better and the winning even with
black so instead of Queen to E2 the only
move uh and now uh ding plays Bishop
captures on H3 he has to give up the
bishop somehow and this is how he
decides to do it and he was very low on
time so he didn't find the precise way
to do a precise way would have been the
trade on E3 and after F captures played
this beautiful Bishop to G4 move that
was the only way for ding to continue
fighting here point now is that you will
have to close up the the G file so the
black king cannot get attacked you will
have to play something like Bishop
captures Knight captures you will have
to play H Captain G4 and now Rook to H4
and black can continues the game so it's
it's like that but Bishop captures and
H3 was played by Ding and now comes G
captures an H3 opening up the G file
King the f8 trying to run away with the
King and yes if ding uh can get his King
all the way to the queen side then he
should be fine but that's a lot of moves
with the King and an open board Ponte H4
defending the bishop with Bishop to D4
and now uh Anish plays A Beautiful
Beautiful Exchange sacrifice so first he
sacrifices a piece for the attack now he
continues with a beautiful uh positional
exchange sacrifice Rook captures on D4
and uh yes uh I know you guys know this
because you follow the the games live
using a strong engines a bishop to B5 is
the move that the engine wants you to
play but it's uh for a human you don't
find this in 20 moves or at all I I will
show it okay Bishop to B5 now uh the the
point is that black has no active moves
let's say Rook to H5 at some point black
will have to give up a rook for this
special because those Rooks are
absolutely useless and now after let's
say Pawn to F4 upon the c6d captures B
captures now you're gonna play F
captures on E5 and after Rook captures
some G5 now you will play H Captain G5
Bishop captures on E3 with check Queen
captures and now let's ignite the G4
attacks the White Queen here but the
just Queen to A7 now puts pressure on
the knight uh Rook to H2 threatening
Checkmate and now look at this queen to
A8 with check King to G7 uh Rook
captures on F7 with checking captures
and The Rook captures on D7 with check
and of course the black king now gets
checkmated on the open board with
unliking the A6 Queen captures on C6
check and so on so that's one way to do
it but it's still uh unclear like after
King to F5 where's the Checkmate Bishop
the D3 check King captures and G5
where's the Checkmate and the black is
still threatening uh Queen characters on
B2 so you're gonna have to play Bishop
to C2 and okay of course white uh will
will prevail here but one uh you know
slight uh misstep and you're gonna
you're gonna be the one who gets
checkmated so okay uh the engine sort of
is screaming Bishop to B5 but it's not
like uh there's something to calculate
unless you're an engine you're not
playing this so Rook captures on D4 is a
human move and it's a beautiful one and
that uh Anish plays it e captures on D4
and now Knight to F5 just taking away
very important squares in front of the
black king also if the if the black
queen moves from the control of these
seven squares just Checkmate so here
Rook captures on G5 because the Rooks
are
non-existent here Rook captures on G5 H
captors and now Knight the E5 getting
the Knight into the attack attacking the
bishop here instead of 95 you could also
consider Knight the E4 it's a very
tricky move uh point is that after
Bishop to D3 you play Knight to C3 and
after captures and captures it looks
like black is getting uh some tricky
positions here let's take the D1 Queen
captures an A4 check King the E1 Queen
to A1 check Queen to D1 and now Queen to
A3 you're gonna block the pawn with
Bishop to C2 and now for example Rook to
H3
so white is winning here but it's uh I
mean it's a very ugly position to have
so maybe not the not a terrible idea but
ding went for Knights the E5 and now
finally comes Bishop to B5 with knight
uh after G4 now uh Anisha has some 11
minutes and the clock being has three
minutes on the clock and just King to B1
you uh you have three minutes on the
clock ding you decide what you want to
do with them I'm playing King to B1
getting out of all the nasty business
and uh there's no good way to continue
uh one way is to play D3 sort of to
maybe give up the pawn to open up some
lines of attack towards the white king
but it's really uh not doing anything so
King to G8 was played uh and now of
course the position is completely
winning and Anish finds it Knight the H6
with check and the point is if you if
you trade then uh the the G file opens
up but you don't really have an option
of not trading because the Knight will
hang and then you're just gonna lose
both of the knights for this Knight on
H6 so here are Knight captures and H6
was played now first queen captures on
E5 the Knight on H6 still hanging
Knights the G4 and now Queen captures on
C7 with the threat of advancing the fast
Pawn but also with the thread of just
Queen to C8 check picking up the Knight
on G4 so there are too many threats here
for ding to handle King to G7 now G6 uh
anise just completely obliterates the
world classical Champion uh we have uh
rooked also if you just capture I mean
you can't really do it just Rook to G1
and if you play A5 then F3 again just
completely winning uh so after G6 Rook
to fa displayed uh we have Queen uh
captures on F7 D3 now but Rook to G1
attacks the Knight with Rook captures on
F7 attacking the queen and here you
could win a whole lot of ways like Queen
to E5 check is winning because if King
to a faith Queen to each eight wins if
you walk into G then D6 just uh there's
I mean there are no moves here for black
but Anish just played Queen to C3 check
another beautiful human move that forces
ding to resign and he was in this
position on move 36 that dingler and
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is uh
you will uh the Queens are coming off
the board and the ones the Queens come
off the board let's say queen captures
on C3 there's Rook captures on G4 with
check and after King to fate you're just
gonna pick up the queen and now you're
up a full Bishop so of course there's uh
and there's no playing this uh I mean an
end game being down a piece so brilliant
stuff by Anish uh be a beautiful uh
beautiful uh Italian game demonstration
of how you can even even without going
for some you know Evans Gambit or some
two nights uh two nights the uh the the
defense uh you could produce a
masterpiece even against a world
champion so absolutely it's a
spectacular stuff here and as promised I
will show you the line that we've
discussed where the win was missed if
you really allow the engines to crush
crunch the numbers uh you know up to uh
maybe depth 50. uh here where Anish
played the D4 there was the incredible
Knight to F5 check forcing a trade
because okay the uh the queen would be
lost so captures captures now with the
queen and now how do you continue here
uh Knight b37 you need to get the Knight
into the game now Rook Dita E1 is what
our good uh friendly engine suggests and
after ding would start running away with
the King now Ponte h for adding a
defensive resource here to the bishop
quanta C6 Now Pawn to F4 this is how the
f file opens up which is kind of what
Anish prepared with that Rook Dev one
move it captures an F4 only now point to
the four and after Bishop to B8 as uh
the point is there are no moves for
black the knights are terrible the Rooks
non-existent the bishop doesn't have a
good diagonal Queen doing nothing so uh
it's uh it's basically a position where
black has has absolutely nothing and now
let's say Bishop to B3 Rook to G6
knocking the B1 those are all some very
very expensive engine moves Rook H7 now
Rook captures an F4 Rook Gita Rook H the
G7 now Rook to F3 and after Queen to E8
and now comes Pawn to E5 D captures an
e5d captures on E5 and there's nothing
if the bishop moves then you can pretty
much play anything and it's winning uh
and uh if um you play Bishop captures
and E5 which of course you can then just
to Rook the E3 now the bishop is being
attack three times so after Knight the
D5 blocking the light score Bishop he
will simply trade Rook captures on E5
Knight captures an E5 Rook captures an
E5 The Rook will block uh Rook captures
Queen captures and now look at this
spectacular win Queen captures an E6 F
captures an E6 and now finishing it with
a beautiful Bishop to H6 and you're
probably thinking okay we'll just give
back the exchange and the game continues
nope not happening because
um uh you can't do it if you move the
king and you just trade here uh let's
say Bishop Bishop captures and G7 King
captures white would capture the Knight
immediately and after he captures on the
5g4 you're up upon in a king and pawn
end game of course this is completely
winning and not only that those are two
connected pass pawns on the king side uh
nothing to discuss here and the other
point is that if you don't want to allow
this you have to play Knight F4 or
Knight to E3 threaten the G2 pawn and
give up the full piece in order to end
up with a rook Against The Bishop's pair
but even this even if you capture the
the pawn here like the bishop captures
an E6 you're up upon you have a bishop
pair against The Rook absolutely winning
so nothing to discuss here so it's a
it's a disgusting Engine line and I know
how you know you guys some of you really
like them some of you don't so that's
why I decided to show it after the
actual game uh but yeah it seems that
there was a win here uh maybe not with
the immediate D4 maybe if they played a
perfect game maybe he could have
defended there but with this Knight to
F5 checkmu so really tricky stuff I hope
hope you enjoyed that as well and yeah
beautifully done by Anish uh we're gonna
probably check up one more game from
this round so then we're going to
discuss the standings but things are
very very exciting after seven rounds of
the super bet chess classic
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh very very tough
tournament for ding but I guess he he is
uh you know overly tired uh as his
nipple after that they're grueling World
Series championship match but also uh
Anish just played a an absolute
Masterpiece here uh so yeah I would like
to thank Lord of Bones thank you for
videos Dr Heisenberg and the ding fan
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event uh
until it finishes uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day